[MUSIC PLAYING]
JINGYU SHI: Hello.
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to Improving Battery
Life with Restrictions.
My name is Jingyu.
I'm a developer advocate
from the Partner DevRel team.
AMITH YAMASANI: Hi, I'm Amith.
I'm a software engineer on
the Android Framework team.
JINGYU SHI: So today, we want
to start with this notification
that we've all
received, hopefully
never around this
time of the day.
Knowing that our
battery is running out
can be really frustrating
and sometimes scary,
depending on where we are and
what we're doing at that time.
These days, we rely so much
on our devices for navigation,
talking to our
friends and family,
taking pictures, and even
translating for us when we're
traveling in a foreign country.
But all these cool features
and amazing apps that you built
cannot help the user if
their battery is dead.
So that's why
today, we're talking
about how we're going to
improve battery with your help,
hopefully, and this is
what we are going to cover.
First, we'll talk about
what's consuming power
and how we measure
power consumption.
And then we're going to go
through the power saving
features we introduced
in recent years.
And in the end, we're
going to talk about
how your app will be affected
by these restrictions,
and what you can do
to work with them.
Next, I'll pass it
over to Amith to talk
about what's consuming power.
AMITH YAMASANI: Hi.
Quickly walk through
how we actually
estimate how an app consumes
power, how much power
it's consuming on the device.
These are the typical
hardware components
that are consuming power
on a typical phone.
I've highlighted some
of the top consumers.
You got an earful about
display and how much power that
consumes from Chris and Alan.
Running the CPU at
high frequencies
is also pretty expensive,
and transferring data
over the cell network is
quite expensive as well.
So when each device
is manufactured,
the OEM provides something
called a power profile.
What the power profile
contains is the average current
drawn by various
subsystems that we
want to measure in real time.
And for example, if
you turn the screen
on at minimum brightness, it
might be about 100 milliamps,
and if you crank it
up to full brightness,
depending on the
technology, let's say
it adds another 300 milliamps.
So we keep track of
that in real time.
CPU at different frequencies
has different power consumption,
so we add that in the
power profile as well.
At runtime, what
we do is, there's
a subsystem called
battery stats.
It tracks what
each app is doing.
It measures how
long it's consuming
each of these resources,
like how much CPU time,
at what frequency, how many
data packets it's transferring,
and so on.
We take those
values, and then we
multiply with the
power cost for each
of those in the power profile.
And we get an
approximate estimate
of how many milliamp hours the
particular app has drained.
And then we rank all
the different apps
based on their consumption,
present it to the user
so they can see
that in settings,
and then they can learn
for themselves what's
really draining their battery.
So let's talk about how the
OS is trying to help the user
extend their battery life.
But first, broadly
speaking, there
are two reasons why an app runs.
Right?
The user's launching it.
It's running in the foreground.
User's actively using the app.
Now as developers,
that's something
you don't want
them to not do, but
that's a whole different
topic about digital well-being
and trying to help users
control how much time they
spend on apps.
But one note I want to leave
about that here because we're
not going to talk
too much about it
is there is a concept
about suspending apps.
And that's something you
might want to read about
and how that impacts your app
if the user suspends the app
for, say, the rest of the day.
But we'll focus on how we
try to limit background
activity from an app.
And app can schedule background
work by using jobs or alarms
or setting up a
background service.
It can also register
for callbacks
for external triggers, such
as a push message or you
walking past a geofence.
So over the years, we've
introduced several features
in the OS to save battery.
First in Marshmallow, we
introduced Doze or Deep Doze.
As the name suggests,
it puts the device
into a really deep sleep
under the condition
that the device is not moving.
So let's say you left it on
your desk or on your nightstand,
you forgot to plug it in.
It basically shuts down a lot
of the background activity
so that you can really
extend your battery life.
But this is not really how
we use our daily phones.
Right?
We are walking around with it.
We're using it
throughout the day.
So we came up with Doze
on-the-go or Light Doze.
What that does is it puts the
device into a slightly lighter
sleep and wakes
up more frequently
so that it has an opportunity to
see if there's any pending work
to do so that your data
is reasonably fresh.
But it's not in front of you.
You're not using the
screen, so it can shut down
some of the background work.
You're probably all familiar
with the Oreo restrictions
on background
services as well as
limiting the number
of implicit broadcasts
that you can wake up to.
And as of this
month, everyone needs
to target Android Oreo or
above because otherwise,
you can't publish
to the Play Store.
But we'll focus more on what's
new in P, Adaptive Battery, app
restrictions or
background restrictions,
and we've also made some
improvements to Battery Saver.
Adaptive Battery is
actually an evolution
of App Standby that
was introduced back
in Marshmallow along with Doze.
What App Standby
did was put apps
into two possible states, active
or inactive, based on usage.
Adaptive Battery extends
this into four buckets
now, where active is
the least restricted.
And based on usage, we move it
into some of the other buckets,
and rare is the most restricted.
For instance, if
you are Google I/O
and you install the
I/O app, by now,
it should have gone
to the rare bucket
because you haven't
been using it.
So how does the OS assign
these buckets to each app?
It starts off when
you're installing
the app in a never bucket.
It's not shown here.
It's really not that relevant.
But once you launch
the app or every time
you launch the app or any
kind of strong interaction
like clicking on a
notification from the app,
the app goes into
the active bucket.
And it stays there for a while,
and maybe in a few hours,
it comes down to the
working set where
it starts applying
restrictions on what
you can do in the background.
And then a little later, most
frequent and then to rare.
And then we uninstall your app.
I'm just kidding.
We don't do that.
[LAUGHTER]
And if there is some kind
of an indirect interaction,
such as you're looking
at a notification
by pulling down the shade,
it's not a clear indication
that it's an active
usage of the app.
So we put it in a
slightly restricted state,
which is the working set.
What is actually
adaptive about this
is if the device happens
to have a machine learning
algorithm, what it does is it
watches your usage patterns,
learns over time, and
then it decides, OK,
this app is probably
going to be used
in the next couple of hours.
Let me put it in the
active set, and maybe it
can freshen up its data.
Maybe it needs to download
the latest news or whatever.
And once it feels that
maybe the app is not
going to be used for a
while, it might move it
into one of the lower buckets.
So this actually really
improves our ability
to reduce the amount of work
that apps do in the background.
And it's not your
fault. It's just
you don't know when the
user is going to launch you,
so we're trying
to help with that.
App restrictions
is another feature,
which is kind of an extreme
version of background limits.
We really limit what the app
can do in the background.
So it's mostly meant
for apps that you just
want to be doing work
in the foreground.
There are two ways the
app can go into the state.
The user might see in
settings that your app
is draining battery and decides
to manually restrict the app.
The other way is the system
is monitoring certain criteria
about how the app is
behaving, and if it
feels that it's doing anything
excessive over certain
thresholds that we set,
it suggests to the user,
hey, do you want to restrict
this app because it is draining
your battery in the background.
These are things that
we will improve over
time, the kind of criteria
and the thresholds.
And OEMs are also free to
add their own criteria.
So what is restricted if an
app is background restricted?
The usual jobs, alarms,
foreground services.
You can't run a
foreground service
if your app is in
a restricted state
because as far as the
user is concerned,
it is still kind of
a background thing
if you see something
happening with a notification
and it's doing work
in the background.
FCM, as of January, will
be restricted as well.
So you won't get any
messages when your app
is in the restricted state.
You also don't get
location updates.
And one thing that's unique
about app restrictions
is, even while the
device is charging,
we don't let you run
in the background.
This is not true for any
of the other restrictions.
And the reason is this is not
just about saving battery.
It's also about annoyances
and maybe privacy concerns.
Battery Saver was
improved in Pie as well.
It's very similar to how
app restrictions work,
but it applies it
across all the apps.
Some of the differences
are foreground services
are OK to run while
in Battery Saver
because you might want
to be listening to music
while on Battery Saver.
There are no restrictions
on push messages.
Network is restricted, jobs
and alarms, the usual ones.
And one thing
that's new in Pie is
we turn off location
services completely,
at least on Pixel devices.
OEMs might not
choose to do that.
So we have some
APIs that you can
use to detect which state you
are in, which restricted state.
For example, you
can ask usage stats
what is your current standby
bucket at this moment.
But if you want to
debug something or want
to know how frequently
you're in some rare bucket,
you can also get
historical information
about your standby
bucket changes.
You can also check
if you are background
unrestricted right now.
And maybe you want to tell
the user something about that
or maybe your critical
services will not work.
But please don't nag the user.
If they don't want you to run,
they don't want you to run.
And you can also check
if Battery Saver's on.
Internally, it's called
Power Saver Mode.
Hand it back to Jingyu.
JINGYU SHI: Thank you, Amith.
So how is your app affected?
So anytime, to the
system, your app
will be in one of
these two states.
It will be either in the
foreground or the background.
And whenever your app is
considered to be in foreground,
all these restrictions
are lifted so you
can run whenever you need to.
But when your app
is in background
and the device is not charging,
all of the Battery Saver
features that Amith just
talked about, any of them
could be enabled, which
means that your jobs, alarms,
network access, and FCM
messages could be restricted.
And next, we have some
really beautiful diagrams,
which will show you
how they are affected.
First, let's look at
the scheduled jobs.
Given that all the constraints
you have on the job
is satisfied, these
are the features,
which will affect when
this job will get run.
First, let's look
at the device level.
If the device is in
Doze, then your job
will be deferred to
maintenance window.
And then if user decide to
turn on Battery Saver or app
restrictions, meaning restrict
your app from their battery
setting, your job
will be deferred
until user opens the app or
when the app is in foreground.
And if none of those
are true, then it's
up to App Standby Bucket or
Adaptive Battery in Pixel.
Your job could be
deferred up to 24 hours.
That's when your app
belongs to the rare bucket.
And that's the worst case,
which means that even
in the worst case, your job
will still get run every day.
So similarly, for
AlarmManager alarms,
these features will affect
when your alarms fire.
When device is in
Doze, your alarm
will be deferred to
maintenance window.
And if the user turn
on Battery Saver
or they restrict
your app, your alarm
will be deferred until
your app is in foreground.
And finally, onto the
App Standby Bucket,
your alarm could be
delayed up to two hours
if your app belongs
to that rare bucket.
So if your use case really
requires that exact time
execution, for example if
you want to remind the user
they need to take
medicine or a TV program
that they subscribe
to is about to start,
so for these use cases, you can
use this site while idle method
that we provided so your
alarm will fire on time.
But when you are using
AlarmManager to wake
up the device frequently--
and imagine that if
every app is doing
that at a different time--
then you are draining
a lot of battery.
That's why we have the excessive
wakeup on your Android vitals
page.
So if you see your excessive
wakeup on vitals page
is caused by AlarmManager,
I would highly
recommend that you
think about, maybe
it's time for you to
migrate to some other APIs
like JobScheduler.
If you are sending
push notifications,
you are probably already using
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
And similarly, your FCM
messages will also be affected.
When the device is in Doze,
your normal priority messages
will be deferred to the
maintenance window, which
means that if you're sending
high priority message,
that message will be
delivered immediately.
This is because high
priority FCM message,
they are created to
trigger action that's
visible to the user like
sending a notification so user
can act on it.
And if the user turn on
Battery Saver, then still,
your messages will be
delivered as it is.
As Amith mentioned earlier,
if the user restricted
your app, currently, the
messages are still delivered.
But as of January next year
2019, all these messages
will be discarded
because this is
a strong signal from
the user that they
want to restrict the app.
And finally, in the
App Standby Bucket,
there's a different
cap on each bucket
that your app could belong to.
The more active the bucket is,
the more high priority message
you can send.
But if you reach that
quota, don't worry.
We're not discarding
your message.
We're just downgrading them
to normal priority, which
means that they could be
delayed a little bit when
device is in Doze.
So if you really want
to reach your user
with that important message,
don't use high priority
for operations that don't
require user interaction.
Whenever you're
sending high priority,
it should trigger a
notification or something
user can interact with.
OK, here's a summary of
the power saving features
that we talked today.
One thing to note is that all
of these features we see here,
they will apply
on any app that's
running on Android 9
device no matter which
target SDK you are targeting.
So our first advice to you
is, please test your app
against all of these features.
We have adb command
on the developer dock
you can use to put your app
in all of these features
and test your use cases to see
if your push notifications are
coming through.
If your job is running, are
you handling that case well?
The good news is except for
the high party FCM message
restriction that
I just mentioned,
actually none of the
other restrictions is new.
We had them since Doze.
So if your app works
well under Doze,
it's very likely
that you don't need
to change much to work
with these features.
Our second advice
to you is, whenever
you're running task
in the background,
please keep in mind to use this
lazy first design principle.
Try to reduce the work you're
running in the background.
Think about, do I really need
to run in the background.
Can this wait until my
app is in foreground?
And think about, do I need
to run with this frequency.
Maybe reduce some work I
am doing in the background.
And if you really need
to run in the background,
try to defer that
work to a later time,
say, when device is
plugged in or think
about that exact alarm.
Does it have to happen
at that exact time?
Can it wait?
And finally, try to coalesce the
work you do in the background.
So in Lollipop, we
introduced JobScheduler,
which is a way for you to help
the system to intelligently
batch all the background work.
And this year, we
introduced the WorkManager
in Jetpack, which makes
running background work easier.
And when it hits stable, it
will be the recommended way
to do background work.
So with that in mind, let's
look at this upgraded view
of how you do things
in the background.
If you need to
execute a work or do
a sync that's
deferrable locally,
then WorkManager is your answer.
If this work is
triggered online,
then you would use a FCM
message with WorkManager,
meaning you would want
to use FCM message
to notify your app that there
is some work you need to do
or you need to sync
with the app server.
And then in the message
handler, you enqueue that work.
If your user case doesn't fit
with either of these cases
and you need to run
something at that exact time,
then you would want
to use AlarmManager.
Finally, if this is something
that the user started,
user is aware that it's running
and it must happen immediately
right now, then you would
use foreground service.
But please whenever you're
using this foreground service,
add that action in the
notification because there is
nothing more frustrating than
seeing a bunch of notifications
but there's nothing I can do
about them because foreground
service notification,
you cannot dismiss them.
So please add that action
in a notification for user
to stop this service.
And then notification
is dismissed.
And if you reach the end, I
would say, go back to the top
or you should wait until
your app is in foreground.
So we have a WorkManager
talk later today at 1:00 PM.
Please go to that to learn
how you can use WorkManager
to do background work.
And we also have a
lot of best practices
and guidance on how you can
to help users save battery
in this power block series.
Please visit to learn more, and
we will be in the office hours
this afternoon
for any questions.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]